on episode 50-ish of the anime culture
corner starting a manga
or manhua i guess getting obsessed with
it and catching up to the current
chapter in a single day because he has
nothing better to do
solo leveling now the last time i made
one of these videos i think was with
record of ragnarok a couple months ago
so this is the first time in a while
that i've really binged a series and
after catching up all i can tell you is
that any hype you've heard about solo
leveling
it's true this manhua is fire
it's gas it's a lit match in a gas
station
in the middle of hell it's that flame
i literally could not peel my eyes off
the computer screen when i was reading
it is so utterly addicting and
captivating
and so today i'm breaking down
spoiler-free of course
what i love about solo leveling if i can
even get to all of that in just one
video
and everything that truly makes it stand
out as one of my favorite manhua
manga to this day roll the intro
in the world of solo leveling the gate
appeared 10 years ago that connected our
world to one of full of
magic and monsters in response this
caused many ordinary people to quote
unquote
awaken they receive superhuman powers
that allow them to fight
said monsters and the people who did
this became hunters
and this job of being a hunter is
actually pretty profitable if you're
good at it
you enter gates with parties and defeat
monsters
their armor and crystals within the
gates being worth tons of money should
you survive and actually win
and our main character seong jinwu is a
hunter
but he's renowned as the world's weakest
he's the lowest of the low even among
e-ranks which
is the bottom rank but he must continue
entering gates despite always being
injured and getting beat up every time
to pay his comatose mom's medical bills
but after a gate gone wrong jinwoo wakes
up in a hospital
finding a menu screen in front of him
that no one else can see
this system as it is dubbed forces him
to become a player
and fulfill a daily quest consisting of
what is basically a one punch man
exercise routine
and if he doesn't fulfill these daily
requirements to become stronger then he
faces a significant penalty
and through this system that is akin to
a single player game almost
woo realizes that he can actually become
stronger and
level up hence the title through earning
xp and
item drops a feat that is thought to be
impossible among hunters
once you awaken normally your power
limit is set
you can't grow or get stronger however
with jinwoo's new unique power
who used to be the world's weakest sets
out on a journey to become one of the
most
fearsome hunters the world has ever seen
the easiest comparison i can draw this
series to at surface level at least
is one punch man the way that we see a
super weak main character become
immensely strong
and constantly be underestimated as he
shocks the world
meeting this organization full of
dynamic and interesting hunters
or heroes in one punch man that seong
jinwu interacts with
there's there's a lot of similarities
but i would be hard-pressed to mention
much other than that because solo
leveling has a lot of differences
and has a much darker and complex system
driving the series
that puts it leagues ahead of one punch
man or any anime like this for me
first off the main character jinwoo has
to be one of the coolest
most badass overpowered main characters
i've ever seen
saitama kirito goku all of them in my
opinion don't hold a candle to this guy
i mean to start with jinwoo has
astronomical drip
this dude never misses on any outfits
and in my eyes he definitely rivals
top-tier anime fashion kings like ichigo
i mean is there anything cooler than
being awesome
dominating your opponents and shocking
really cool hunters
and looking good doing it he starts off
as this really scrawny kid
but as he gets more skill points and
increases his stats through the system
it is physically reflected in his body
type too
and the man upgrades his fashion to go
along with it
which actually brings me to my next
point which is just how satisfying it is
to watch
jinmu get stronger throughout the
manhunt
because of the way solo leveling works
and how jinmu is basically
leveling up through this internal quest
log of his
the story is very similar to a single
player adventure game
he picks up cool items that get better
as his enemies get stronger
some of which even have like set bonuses
they can heal stats or boost his
strength attribute by 15.
he can get specific skills too like this
one that literally gives him the force
and lets him force
choke people and throw them around like
their toys
and one called bloodlust that stops
enemies in their tracks
out of pure fear he also earns a class
later on
something that all hunters have like
mage or healer
but because of how this internal game
works he's not just
op in his specific class he's op
in like every single category there is
throughout the story these high tier
hunters think they have him all pinned
down and figured out
but then he uses insane healing assassin
tricks
and close combat skills that are all so
strong
equally that no one can even comprehend
it
and the best part is all of these items
and skills
come back later on in the story nothing
is forgotten they all remain
in his inventory and it's just so
immensely satisfying to see the physical
manifestation
of jinwoo's wins through his new skills
or items he acquires
the best parts of playing your own
single player game in real life
is finding these really rare items that
drops from bosses
and unlocking really cool but niche
skills through like a skill tree
we see all of this through solo leveling
as jin wu gets stronger
and as a big fan of games like the
witcher 3 and skyrim
this is straight up just like that and
it's so much fun
not to mention just like in those top
tier adventure games
the world building in solo leveling is
awesome
i mean you really get engrossed in it we
start off on this really small scale
as we learn the ins and outs of how
gates and ranks and hunters work as
jinmu gets onto his feet we see the
micro scale of the daily life of hunters
and how desperate it can get for small
timers just trying to make a living
while risking their lives
every day and then as jinmu gets
stronger we get introduced to a huge
cast of strong hunters with really
dynamic powers
turning into beasts fire skills
it starts in south korea where the story
originates and we meet
s rank hunters which is the top tier but
then later on it expands to the whole
world
where we realize that the top s rank
isn't even enough to describe just how
strong some of the people in the world
are
that there are even nation-level hunters
who have the power rivaling kings
simply because of how strong they are
and as expected with so many other cool
human characters
it means that jinmu isn't just fighting
monsters all the time
even though these fights are cool and
awesome and the monster character
designs are also dope the best part of
the series for me
stems from his interactions and
conflicts with other hunters
there will be times when he meets them
and he can't even hold a candle to them
but after going through a dungeon and
leveling up a lot he comes back and
overpowers them completely since he's
literally the only hunter out there who
can
continuously get stronger and every
hunter has a specific power according to
their class
and i won't spoil but jinwooz is
insanely cool
he literally sets the standard of what
it means to be a one-man army and it's
just so
badass how his skills improve and the
various ways he uses it in both a combat
setting
and just in normal life as well
the manhua also never really slows down
it's like you're on a moving train
watching jinwu improve and battle
constantly
and then the moment the train stops
another boss
steps on the train along with loads of
new plot information that can
barely fit onto the carriage itself
like it is so hard to stop reading
because every chapter you're introduced
to something new
or you're in the middle of a huge fight
and the mantra itself has actually been
split up onto two seasons so far
the first season is really good it
focuses a lot more on jinwoo's personal
growth of course because it's the
beginning of the story
and coming to grips with being a strong
hunter and finding his place in the
world
and the idea of improving in this almost
game-like setting
and finding items and new skills is
really important
it also has a lot more emphasis on other
side characters in fleshing out the
world
but a big part of the story is actually
jinwoo trying to understand the
origin of his powers as it is unheard of
for a hunter to be able to constantly
get stronger
and i mean no surprise here there is
more to his power
and thus in the second season it's
focusing a lot more on that overarching
plot
and also jin will loki just flexing how
strong he is on everyone else
but it's also a lot darker and more
serious now
so in that sense the moment it feels
like jinmu hits a wall
or the train is reaching its last
destination in solo leveling
it's like a plane just comes and swoops
him up instead and were taken to a whole
different world and
setting to be engrossed in once again
the series never stops getting bigger
and throwing new things your way and it
honestly left me in awe how amazing it's
been so far
i cannot wait to keep reading the series
and see where it goes
what do you guys think if you've read
solo leveling did you like it as much as
i did
it's honestly just awesome there's no
other words i have for it
if you haven't gotten around to it or
even heard of it before today
i highly recommend it please read it
guys
it's so good as always this has been the
anime culture corner i hope you enjoyed
the video don't forget to like and
subscribe for future in-depth show
manga and character analyses
you